[Music]
and welcome back to another exciting
episode of careful boys featuring a very
very lovely careful girl here we have
julia julia challenged back in the
building
unless you want like careful day then
whatever works well i mean it's usually
careful boy no matter if they're a guy
or girl you're a careful boy yeah right
pounded what's up dog
what's up bruh what's up
bra doesn't really work as well like it
works well good
works i thought it was nice
it's like
yeah you know what i mean
what's up bro yeah what's up so how you
been bro
it's good it's good um give us the
lowdown
on life just working things are slowing
down a lot so i'm taking a break
we know that but um okay so personal
life wise how are
things uh it's good yeah yeah uh because
now i have this break i can do a lot
more self-care time very cool what do
you plan on doing yeah what's top
priority self-care um
oh i got them i got a massage the other
day which is really nice yeah it was
like a thai massage the lady like
freaking
contorted me like did she step on do
they credit card your butt
no they did not and you know what though
i did see a sign
in their store saying like we are an
authentic thai massage place and i was
like oh that's so sad that like that
they had so many people asking them like
oh no credit carding we don't do it stop
asking jojitsukawa
hey not me but my friend's friend he's
notorious for doing these jacking off
places right and then so like he got so
used to doing it that one day he went to
a legitimate place
and then um he asked for a special
finish
your friend mo and then the ladies they
were like what the [ __ ] and then they
kicked them out
who who which one of was it was it you
who who sent the um that website that
like shows all the [ __ ] yeah
maps roadmap ch robbie
is this guy just there he's just like
i'll have the special finish
he's like can i do that after the hot
stones please i think i'm ready for my
special finish
whenever you're ready my special footage
let's be ready
that's so sick because thai places do
not do that right oh think so the
legitimate ones you guys do you guys
think if i walked in there
they were going no no no no
no we don't jerk you off okay get the
[ __ ] out of here out the front door get
the [ __ ] out of here they were calling
the cops
yeah right sicko get out of here have
you guys ever like imagined something
cuz you know like you're in there for an
hour right so you're in your head and
have you imagined something so funny and
you couldn't stop dude containing your
lap any time they touched my toes it
started giggling like and then like
you never had that uh-uh dude i had two
times the first one was when i went to
get the massage in like little tokyo
back in the day and the lady put on the
[ __ ] final fantasy viii soundtrack
you start crying
that's actually funny that's incredible
and it was like an actual cd and she put
it in i was like how the [ __ ] did you
like who does that maybe she's like
right she gets an immediate boner i know
i just lift up off the table face down
and then another time is when when uh
as quest we all got massages in the
philippines and then we're separated by
these curtains so we could kind of like
hear what the other uh masseuse is
saying on the other side
and then like at one point uh we all
have like these little shorts on
whatever
and then the first masseuse like um
my masseuse was like pulling it down and
she goes she goes
okay sir i'm going to expose your
buttocks okay
and i was like all right
and like i know they heard it and then
the next i hear his lady
okay sir i'm going to expose your
buttocks okay like three in a row
and then all three of us started busting
up because
it was like a [ __ ] echo chamber like
the next person
man there's no
no room for creativity for these people
they can't do their own order yeah
that's so polite but it's also the
sentence of like i'm going to expose
your buttocks that's very good
who says
well in a filipino accent that shit's
just it can only be a comedy logic bro
this uh city in china one time getting a
massage right it was uh some of the
changes
one of them one of them was bam though
and uh we so it's four of us we get in
there we line there and then four ladies
walk in they start speaking chinese only
one of us understands chinese by the way
nice right and they're saying some stuff
but we don't really know what's going on
and then john starts laughing by himself
so we're like oh like what's going on
right and then he literally tells us
afterwards he's like they came in and
then one by one they looked around at
all of us and then slowly kept on saying
i don't want to do the dark one
bands of filipino godly he's just the
darker one out of us
light-skinned southeast asian guys oh no
what what happens what happens if they
get the darker one no i don't she was
like massaging my face so to to my
knowledge of according to what my mom is
saying and what my mom's friends there's
history to this yeah cause like my mom's
little racist club
their clan rally yeah inner joy luck
clan joy look clap your friend
yeah they're just saying like uh because
they don't like their own like
acupuncture or like massage practice and
they're just saying like that the darker
skinned customers that come in the
smellier they are and i was like wow
that's just mean
that's just me and she was like
it's facts she was like saying like yeah
like the darker the skin like toy luck
clan for real and i was like wow
wow yeah that's that's your next movie
you guys
are welcome that is true though because
when when i was in malaysia and it was
me and my my homie we're doing shows out
there and he's tall black dude and then
he called for a massage and he we didn't
know [ __ ] at the time we didn't know
that when you called for a massage like
in malaysia there's just gonna a taxi
will show up with like four girls and
you pick and it's basically just a it's
a oh yeah but he wanted a real massage
he just saw that he opened the little
book in the hotel and they just had a
number it's just straight up in a phone
book it's in like a book in the room
yeah and it's so they the taxi
called the one with the girl in a bikini
there's no photos so then this taxi
comes and it has like four girls in it
like all like hella young and then uh
they all look at him and then they just
go
drive yeah and then and then the the
taxi guy goes hey
treat her like your girlfriend like
don't don't be mean to her and then he
was like what the [ __ ] are you guys
talking about because i guess like he's
like you know what i mean you know
you know what i mean
i guess what what the deal is is that
they will drop a girl off and she stays
with you the whole night and he's going
to pick her up tomorrow
and then my mommy was like dude i just
wanted like a one-hour massage i won't
take care of it i love the racist
supposition though of like hey i know
how all you guys are yeah yeah
just between you and me i i know how you
guys are yeah he was literally like
telling him like don't don't like be
rough with her don't be mean to her just
treat her nice
we all know you guys have big dicks yeah
do you see how small this asian girl is
relax all right so he was like he just
[ __ ] romantic dude he passed on it
and they drove away and then my homie
was like should we like rescue them or
something oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and then he's like can you just
like rub my back real
quick my buddy went to a um
uh uh
like a massage place not knowing it was
a rubbing tug he was like like he was
working at the warehouse and he was just
like [ __ ] man like my back is killing me
so he just found a place on yelp on the
way home he got there and he saw that
like it was like one of those chinese
ones where all the all the people were
getting massaged in one room
like it like it's open right right the
reflexology type stuff with their yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he you know he's
a little overweight and he's just like i
don't feel comfortable like in this room
and he's like you guys have like a
private space and he goes yeah uh
right this way and then they gave him
this room by himself and then the guy
comes out with a binder and he goes do
you think this girl's cute or whatever
and he goes yeah i guess so
and then he didn't really understand why
and a girl comes in
and then um you know he lays down and
then she just jacks them off but in the
in the minute like i was like you didn't
tell her to stop he goes no i felt good
so i couldn't resist because when he
tried to go away
he was just like oh
and then so
so basically he'd have the power yeah
she didn't beat him up she said she said
that like she she was on his back and
she started like
like one of these like lame ass massages
she goes okay turn around and he goes
huh like they usually don't like turn
you over until like you know toward the
end until they give you a massage on
your back yeah or something so he turned
around and goes oh okay and then so like
and then she pulled down this patch he
goes wait what's happening and then like
he started getting jacked off and he was
like but you know this is kind of nice
too and so after he finished
he was like
can i actually get a real massage
because like my back really hurts and
then she laughed at him and walked away
that's exactly like the topless mate i
got remember holy [ __ ] yeah the topless
man yeah
i was like no we really need to clean
she's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's like i don't have supplies or you
have gloves
you knew she was the top was made right
yeah because that's the only maids that
were working that day
of course you poor son of a [ __ ]
that's like this guy this guy's friend
he's like i don't know i go in to it's
turns out it's a rubber tuck you get i
get i get jerked off i'm not gonna
insult the woman i don't know yeah i'm
not gonna say no to her culture yeah
come on
today's video is brought to you by
babble
you know like as we get older
i feel like
in our multicultural family
we want to get more into the roots
right like i'm more oops yeah more into
like chinese [ __ ] jio's more into
mexican [ __ ] because the more we get
into those things the more taika
gets into those things or else he just
becomes [ __ ] american yeah that's
true because he didn't even know he was
mexican yeah he doesn't even know and
then he'll like he'll like literally
watch uh rubble in the brocks and laugh
at chinese people i'm like that's you
[ __ ] but he doesn't even know so
um in the next year or two we're gonna
try to immerse him a little bit more but
i think the real help comes when you can
cross so i learn more about spanish
mexican stuff and geo learns more about
the chinese stuff which is why i love
babble because you can learn
languages extremely fast because all the
lessons are only just 10 minute segments
and they use real life conversations so
you're not just learning about hey that
is a dog
yeah like who is going to use that on
the street
and they got speech recognition
technology
so you can be so you'll learn how to say
things the right way enunciate enunciate
it more authentically rather than you
just keep practicing on your own and you
end up saying things the wrong way for
years and they use like ai's for their
lesson plans and they had
over 150
language experts to help design this
yeah and they got over 14 different
languages you got spanish german italian
all kinds of stuff so whatever country
you're going to go to you can look to
see if they have it for you and it's
going to be a really fast way to learn
the language right now you can save up
to 60 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com off the record that's
babel.com off the record for up to sixty
percent off your subscription babble
language for life i'd be a racist if i
did yeah i'm not a racist
so you got a massage yeah i i just i
just wanna elaborate on the note like i
don't believe that the darker skin you
are the smell you are i don't think
anyone believes that but it was just
that's well they do prove that wrong
right now
but the joy luck clan believes it oh my
god
they sure did we should say like all old
asian ladies that are hella racist like
they're a part of the joy look yeah
yeah and they're not changing their
minds yeah they're not you can't they've
got they've in their mind they've got
just data it's just factual fact it's
anecdotal but it's true
that they went through so you can't
change this is gonna be a very naive
question yeah um
guys obviously uh right people there's
rub and tug
type of like situations for do girls
ever go into massage parlors and
want a happy ending
yeah not that i know of you know what
i'm saying like i know what would be
a perfect
robin
like if you're like joe's trying to
start a new business up like you can
get finger hammered yeah
like if you could have catalogs like do
you like these fingers
which hands do you like more you could
have a shady massage parlor for women
yeah yeah you know
how would you build services would yeah
what would what would the men look like
how would yeah what kind of services
you know because you know it could be
just like a plethora of dildos maybe
like a saddle with like no bottom on it
but then you put it on a guy's face yeah
oh my god you know something like that
that's [ __ ] genius or do you just
want the masseuse to ask you how your
day was oh yeah yeah i'm patting on that
so don't try to do anything have a
[ __ ] patent yeah what what would the
girl's version be girl's
yeah i think definitely you would have a
catalog of a bunch of guys and i think
you can you can you could you can
compartmentalize it [ __ ] a lot of
siddhartha's how the forearm and below
look you know and just see like oh do
you just want a finger job wow
good job it was right there i said
finger jack hammer so you have you have
a photo of just hands like oh i want the
one with the tattoo it's like yeah you
can just do that yeah nice nice
so they're all hand models are you like
no i don't want the dark ones gonna make
it smell like it's gotta be from the
forearm
just like an infinity stone arm
can't do that one i want it to be smelly
can i get a lighter hand because i've
heard that
you know women are really into like man
hands and i've heard that before like
wow that was those hands are hot
raid our hands around the room you ever
heard of that like i've heard of it
some hands being a deal breaker if they
were like yeah right yeah like geo said
that about tom hardy that's right she
didn't like him because his hands are
weird my strong hand what's wrong with
his hands yeah i don't know she just
said she just went
oh well i don't like gio's hands reading
that yeah yeah yeah take that geo
watching we gotta back up tom hardy here
are there some like traits that you're
like oh i just can't with this guy
because of this physical thing
uh physical like if it's like it feels
nippy have you have you been on a date
or been with someone and you're just
like oh dirty fingernails or like
something you're just like okay yeah
that's really gross
if they touch it they have to wash your
hands man i'm like um
so you make guys wash their hands before
yeah i do i don't give a [ __ ] even take
a shower whoa very good that's very good
it's very intense
it's very good i don't need a girl to
wash her hands when she starts with me
but i see the difference yeah
because one's internal yeah that's true
yeah because jacking a man off is like
doing this
and and fingering a girl it's like doing
this
yeah and you got to wash your hands
before you put them in your mouth that's
right that's just a rule that's why it's
diff it's that's how diseases are spread
we didn't get that on that camera dude
the camera cut off
and then the profile
that's a good example right
so so it would be flicking the beam that
would be like the uh whatever i mean
there's that there could probably be
like a toy bar where you have like a
toy ball
see this is why we need women's
over here
skip it a little simon says yeah
yeah and then you can probably have like
different packages of like what kind of
like you'll skip it
or whatever
that's good yeah
what about like music selection oh
candles space jam soundtrack what's the
vibe like what's the ambiance well yeah
i would probably leave it up to the
customer final fantasy 8 it is is there
beads for doors no greatest hits
i feel like it just depends
yeah yeah everyone was different yeah oh
yeah i wonder like if it would actually
make money because i feel like girls can
get a lot of that for free
oh my god that's so true what the [ __ ] i
think we just waited for five minutes
well i mean there's such thing as like
sugar mamas not but professionals though
they need to be done by professionals
it's discretion discretion she a woman
could waste her time with a guy that
doesn't know how to finger wrong one
yeah but they do that all the time
anyway
they do with all of us yes true but the
experience once you do it like 100 times
a day you know when you're like looking
at you go to the massage parlor you like
look at this old ass granny walk in
you're like no way with a wrinkled hands
and then it's magic she [ __ ] you up she
do i imagine these men having like their
hands and their dick and shirt in case
yeah they should
i'm sorry i don't know nobody brought
dick into this is that good if that old
lady is that good you know that on like
valentine's day she can't even [ __ ]
open door to apartment because so many
flowers in there so many guys who were
like yo this chick thank you
just to [ __ ] push it get someone to
help her push it open there's so many
[ __ ] flowers in there they're putting
at the sliding through adorable yeah
dude perfect and then she's got a guy
coming behind her flower delivery she's
like my god it's getting sandwiched
between the door though
their hands are that good
ftd ma'am
name one thing you miss about being here
[Laughter]
one thing hot that's so hard there's
just so many things name all of them i'm
a couple top five
what what is it well i'll see your
frozen
okay
save it for hot soup
because earlier you said that
after your work you're like i don't know
what to do but my life used to be so
exciting here at jk but that's so boring
and that made me feel great so do more
do more of those do more of that more
more of those quotes this is uh joe's
happy ending i know you guys are just i
don't know it's just so random here like
i just feel like you can freely express
yourself not that i couldn't do it at
work but i just feel you have to have
some form of professionalism uh yeah
that's probably true you weren't letting
you express yourself at work right here
you could sexually harass your bosses
you can and your co-workers and your
co-workers
yeah um it's a very safe space for
people
to not have a professional face yes so
you don't have to be two-faced
yeah and i like how it's just we're just
talking and it's work whereas like when
i'm at work when i'm talking with
somebody or just like trying to catch up
with somebody it's like on works time
water water talk time yeah so then by
the time that you're done talking with
them you're just like oh [ __ ] i have so
much work that i need to do that i got
really distracted and it's not it's
frowned upon when you talk about work
here we want to get to the juice of just
regular shoes it's very true you know
what i mean pretty much yeah i get i get
in trouble when i start reporting news
and stuff yeah it's like too much news
yeah making it too real yeah too much
have you seen old enough for kisses no i
haven't oh yeah let's let's get julia's
take on it this is not
this is yeah we need we need we need her
to see this yeah you need to see it
it's it's just it's part of us now it's
the initiation process yeah we just need
to know your thoughts on this and
whether you think this is chill or or
bunk just total thoughts just whatever
your whatever your reaction is like
we're at a museum and you're looking at
art yeah is this whackers is chill
do you like clint eastwood don't look
yet
he's cool you're gonna love a map how
much do you like him out of tent yeah
he's neutral do you think he's handsome
i think he's like five do you think he's
a handsome old guy he's okay okay here
we go would you make out with them
though no
all right well check this out just i'm
gonna be at this angle so you can see it
very clearly she just let her wait just
just just i want to see her reaction
like that that's fine
what's your name
but everybody calls me amy
i'm corporal john mcburney
but everybody calls me mcbee
12
13 in september
[Music]
all
she's our first no everyone else loves
it everyone loves other women on the
show everyone loves it
julia now you have to present this to
steve yeah give that to steve open it up
and give it a steve yeah and then just
kind of open it up oh my god take it out
of the [ __ ] you did it take it out of
the [ __ ]
you're a legend
so it's this the number 12
and then show the back side to the
camera
13.
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god that's so great
go ahead and give it to steve please go
this is a big moment thank you wow it's
going right off this is great dude but
the team is safe table this is
incredible you can wear
welcome back
julia welcome back
thanks for being a part of this
i'm at a lot of work
september's a great month it's a great
month
you